بالفعل هناك انخفاض بوتيره القصف
الاوكراني على مناطق المدنيين هنا في
مقاطعه حيث اعلن المصدر المحلي هنا بان
اقل من 100 قذيفه وصاروخ سقطت على مناطق
مختلفه من المقاطعه وخلفت خمسه اصابات دون
ضحايا هذه اشارات فاطمه
لتقدم جيش الروسي وسيطرته على محور
المعارك لان القصف عندما يكون عنيف هذا
يعني بان الجيش الاوكراني يتقدم وعندما
تنخفض وتيره اعداد القذائف والصواريخ التي
تسقط عند المدنيين هنا هذا يعني ان الجيش
الروسي بالفعل يتقدم ويتقدم بمحاور عديده
المحور الاهم وهو باخمت كالعاده ربما ليست
هناك اي تطورات كبيره لكن هناك سيطره
للجيش الروسي على احدى البلدات كراس نيجر
منذ عده ايام واكمال تطويق بلده مجاوره
لها وهي اكرسنا
عفوا
بلده براسك المجاوره لكريسنيغارا واللتان
تقبعان بالمحور الشمالي من مدينه باقمت
يحاول الجيش الروسي او قوات فاجنر تحديدا
اكمال الطوق اي شكل دائره كامله على
القوات الاوكرانيه وذلك بقطع الطرق التي
تمد الجيش الاوكراني بالاسلحه والذخيره من
الناحيه الغربيه طريقين وهما
[موسيقى]
بالفعل تقول القوات الاوكرانيه نفسها وكيف
تقول بان الجيش الاوكراني بالفعل يقصف هذه
الطرق السريعه التي تؤمن الامدادات
الغذائيه والعسكريه والبشريه للجيش
الاوكراني ربما تطول مده يعني السيطره او
الدخول الى مدينه باقمت حسب ما قال مؤسس
يعني مقاتلي فاقنر بان الحرب عموما او
اكمال السيطره على مقاطعه دانياس باكملها
تحتاج لاكثر من عام ونصف كما ان يعني
السلطات المحليه هنا تؤكد بان معارك ضاريه
تدور في جنوب المقاطعه اي حول مدينه
اوغلادار